it really started taking off was when it
was one of Oprah's favorite things right
I mean when Oprah likes something it's
just you better be ready that's my
friends it was oh my God I'm going to
cry I mean what did you did you have
enough to sell my God it was honestly I
launched June of 2021 just like 900 each
bottle I was like friends and family
will buy this let's tip the toe I'm not
a chef I'm nothing like let's just start
right yeah AUST I got an email you're
going to be an Oprah for everything I
was like someone is prank
me and I they did not it was real that's
amazing it's it's like winning an Oscar
for two months in a business and then
you got picked up by Oprah yeah when
they called they're like so Uber uh we
know that you just launched your company
but like we wanted to put this in you
know I was like yeah they were like well
can you handle the Opera
effect probably and I'm at Central Park
back trying to be entrepreneur I say
yeah of course yeah yeah of course I can
handle it yeah of course of you never
say no to opportunity yeah so I said yes
oh yeah it was two months of tear
because they were short of gosage
shortage of boxes shortage of employees
because it was like right after pandemic
yeah yeah I would call text I call
everybody I be like uh this company
called uart something amazing is
happening in November please help me
produce cuz I couldn't say I'm going to
be an Opera favor thinging you're not
allowed to say it so I couldn't really
like lead it with a hey you know I'm
going to be an oah thing I couldn't say
that and I'm such by the book I was like
I'm not getting out of this list because
I leaked myself to get yeah no no no I
would yeah and they'll be like who Uber
what I'm like uber hot it's like a
company they're like I'm sorry we don't
know like so people just hang out I was
calling crying I was asking for
Christmas present and a Muslim I was
like please make it a
Christmas please I love you so
much yeah so and then you finally found
a partner finally I found someone in
Ohio shout out to Ohio that's where my
mama's from yeah yeah they're like girl
yeah yeah I call him for a week crying
every day he's like we can't I was like
listen if I ask you for a baby in two
months maybe right but this is hot so we
can work at night I'll come and help you
I'll do whatever you want he's like you
know what someone helped me I'll help
you and then they produced the opra
effect oh my
God
congratulations I'm so grateful oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
God thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home